voici le rez de chaussée de la mairie de
maurepas aujourd'hui et voici à quoi il
ressemblera en juin prochain
un espace lumineux et optimisé pour
guider les visiteurs dans leurs
démarches
cette rénovation qui doit faire passer
le bâtiment à l'ère numérique répond à
plusieurs objectifs
le premier c'est d'améliorer l'accueil
des usagers donc démord pas bien voire
même des personnes qui n'habitent pas
encore mort pas c est également
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des agents de la collectivité
les travaux coûtent 900000 euros ils
sont financés par la mairie qui recevra
une subvention de 180000 euros du
département
la future organisation comprendra un
guichet unique et deux autres niveaux
d'accueil où seront répartis les
visiteurs afin d'éviter les
encombrements faire des travaux au sein
même du rez de chaussée va permettre
d'avoir trois types d'accueil différents
un accueil où on pourra directement
informé les mauraciens sur l'actualité
de la vie vous avez après un deuxième
accueil où il ya plus de confidentialité
pour traiter un certain nombre de sujets
notamment sur l'état civil et vous avez
un troisième niveau d'accueil là il ya
un niveau de confidentialité plus
important ce bâtiment érigé dans les
années 70 avait conservé la même
structure depuis plus de 25 ans c'est
dire s'il était temps de lui donner un
nouveau souffle
il est prévu comme
je les dis dans le cadre des travaux une
isolation pour permettre aussi aux
agents de travailler dans de meilleures
conditions parce qu'avant il y avait des
courants d'air on avait mené plus dans
les moquettes on à du mobilier qui
avaient l'âge de la précédente
rénovation de l'hôtel de ville
cette rénovation s'inscrit dans une
modernisation plus large des services
publics
un site internet baptisé espace citoyen
est ouvert depuis septembre dernier on
peut y réaliser certaines démarches sans
avoir à passer par la mairie